hallo ihr lieben diese frage beschäftigt
uns doch jeden tag sind wir mal ehrlich
was koche ich nur heute und ich habe
heute eine super idee für euch wir
machen einen auflauf mit ganz viel
gemüse um darüber hackbällchen und hier
habe wirklich super wenig geschehen
zeigt euch alles schritt für schritt wir
haben fleisch gemüse und soße in einem
und jetzt zeige ich euch den ersten teil
der zutaten
ich habe hier eine große schüssel voll
gemüse und das ist total variabel
ich habe jetzt hier eine aubergine eine
rote und eine gelbe paprika außerdem
möhren und braune champignons für die
soße benötigen wir passierte tomaten
etwas milch und an gewürzen salz pfeffer
etwas zucker edel süßes paprikapulver
außerdem gemüsebrühe und oregano das
gemüse habe ich so weit vorbereitet
mögen und aubergine habe ich geschält
und in dünne scheiben geschnitten
paprika einfach ganz grob in stücke
schneiden und die champignons die
brauchte gar nicht verarbeiten die gebe
ich gleich so direkt hier rein und ich
verwende für das heutige rezept den
meister da ist das chef den finde ich
total super weil ihr hier ein wenig
geschick habt und alles gleich in der
glasschüssel in den backofen schieben
können wir fangen jetzt an das gemüse
klein zu schneiden und ich starte jetzt
mit den möhren die möchte ich am
liebsten ganz klein weil die werden noch
bissfest nach dem backen und dann habe
ich so ganz klein am liebsten
[Musik]
die möhren habe ich jetzt komplett
verarbeitet und jetzt gehen wir paprika
mit dazu ich habe hier wie gesagt gelbe
und rote aber hier könnt ihr selber
entscheiden welche sorte ihr am liebsten
mit und ihr könnt auch gemüse
untereinander ganz einfach austauschen
für die paprika nämlich jetzt den
länglichen aufsatz und das ist einfach
der gleiche ich verschiebe einfach nur
das gemüse auf die andere seite und dann
habe ich ihm so längliche stücke nachher
[Musik]
so die paprika ist mit drin und als
nächstes verarbeite ich die aubergine
weiter und die mag ich wenn sie nicht
ganz so klein sind wie die möhren aber
auch nicht zu groß deswegen wechsel dich
mahlgrad den einsatz und dann werdet ihr
auch noch daran gegeben
als nächstes geben wir die champignons
mit dazu und ich persönlich mag
champignons total gerne der haben sie
gar nicht aber stets hinter der kamera
du kannst gar nichts daran ändern dass
ich hier champignons reihen gebe ich
noch mehr kurz ein bisschen platz für
den aufsatz und dann gehen wir die noch
mal richtig schön in scheiben da rein
eine noch kommen die letzte geht auch
noch zu spät
und das ist jetzt unser gemüse schaut
mal die akkurat und hübscht das
geschnitten ist und jetzt gehen wir
unsere tomaten sauce dazu und die wird
auch super schnell und einfach das
verspreche ich euch und die soße geht
super einfach ihr braucht weder einen
herd noch im topf oder ähnliches liebe
das wenig aufwand und wenig geschert wir
führen jetzt ganz einfach die passierten
tomaten zusammen mit den gewürzen und
der milch
und das war es auch schon ich habe es
euch ja versprochen wir geben jetzt ganz
einfach unsere soße auf das gemüse und
verrühren das gut so und das war es auch
schon wir machen gleich noch die
hackbällchen deshalb gebe ich das jetzt
zur seite macht den deckel drauf und das
ist eben auch der vorteil ihr könnt es
total gut vorbereitung einfach nach der
arbeit an dem backofen tun oder nach der
schule und dann hat er sofort ein
mittagessen für die hackbällchen
benötigen wir rinder gehacktes an
gewürzen salz pfeffer oregano gemeinen
kreuzkümmel und edel süßes paprikapulver
außerdem eine zwiebel paniermehl und ein
ei und wir geben jetzt alle restlichen
zutaten einmal zudem rinderhack und ich
gebe am liebsten pandemie und ein mit
rein auch wenn es zwei bindemittel sind
ich habe das gefühl dass sie dann doch
ein bisschen besser sind von der
konsistenz her und bei den gewürzen da
brauchte ich auch keine sorgen machen
wenn ihr denkbar so viele gewürze für
ein rezept nee das ist gar nicht so ihr
habt nämlich hier die gewürze parallel
also die gleichen wege auch gerade im
auflauf verwendet habt
die zwiebel ist auch mit drin und jetzt
verkündeten wir das ganze am besten fünf
minuten lang auch wenn es ein bisschen
lang vorkommt also die hackbällchen
werden es euch danken wenn ihr sie
langen knetet und ich bin dafür am
liebsten handschuhe könnt aber natürlich
das ganze auch ohne handschuh kneten
nach fünf minuten merkt er dass der teig
so ein bisschen die konsistenz verändert
und total schön fest wird jetzt nämlich
die handschuhe abmachen meine hände nass
und dann freue mich so kleine bällchen
die hackbällchen sind fertig geformt ich
habe immer einen großzügigen esslöffel
genommen und jetzt gehen wir über zu
unserem gemüse
da gehen wir jetzt nämlich noch zwei
zutaten rein und das ist das geniale das
ist absolut alles andere als ein
langweiliger auflauf denn jetzt kommt
zwei tomaten zum einsatz und
anschließend gouda käse
[Musik]
jetzt nehmen wir uns die tomatenscheiben
und verteilen die so grob auf dem gemüse
und darüber kommt gleich noch unser
gouda käse
[Musik]
so den käse verteilen wir jetzt auch
noch schön
und wer jetzt die tomaten zum beispiel
nicht haben möchte der kann ja auch ganz
einfach weglassen ich sag ich aber kurz
warum ich die noch mit reingenommen habt
weil die western ja richtig schön und
wir haben anschließend nach dem
backvorgang noch so eine richtig schöne
soße für den reis wenig später als
beilage zubereiten also dass man uns als
kleinen hinweis nebenbei ja weil ich die
mark und du nicht ob ich ärgern möchte
so auf dem käse geben wir jetzt noch
unsere hackbällchen wer das ganze
vegetarisch haben möchte der kann das
natürlich auch so in den backofen
schieben dass es auch kein problem
[Musik]
unser auflauf ist fertig vorbereitet und
der wandert jetzt in den vorgeheizten
backofen bei 200 grad ober und
unterhitze für etwa 40 bis 45 minuten
ebenso lang bis die hackbällchen durch
sind so bis gleich
[Musik]
nach der backzeit ist unser
gemüseauflauf mit dem hackbällchen
topping fertig und er schmeckt
unglaublich lecker und ihr habt gesehen
so ein aufwand war das gar nicht bei mir
gibt es heute noch meinen gelben reist
dazu das rezept findet ihr unten in der
infobox wenn ich gerade kein reis er
wäre dann gibt es dazu frisches brot
tunken wir immer schön in die soße super
lecker und ich habe meistens auch zwei
tage was davon dann mache ich den deckel
drauf und am nächsten tag wird es noch
mal aufgewärmt ich schreibe euch
generell alle zutaten in der infobox
macht euch ein screenshot geht einkaufen
und macht nach ich bin gespannt auf euer
feedback hinterlassen video gern einen
like um einen kommentar und den meister
der chef den verlinken sich auch unten
in die infobox dann könnt ihr mal sehen
was da alles und zubehör dabei ist also
was ich euch heute gezeigt hat das war
noch gar nicht da gibt es unglaublich
viele schnitttechniken ansonsten freue
ich mich wenn ihr beim nächsten mal auch
wieder dabei seid jetzt gibt es ja
wieder regelmäßig videos die sommerpause
endlich vorbei ich bin so glücklich
darüber
und ich sag bis zum nächsten mal auf
kies kitchen tschüss